and no one ever complained about your
weight like any producers or directors
or they just embrace it like yeah let
them be the uh overweight kid oh they
loved it i mean i was especially in the
early 2000s like i was
fulfilling a niche like a thing
especially in like why a or kids tv
there was always the fat friend or the
fat bully
and like
that was a big part that was sort of my
inspiration or motivation to lose weight
was like if i really want to act i'm
being relegated
and stereotyped into these like two
parts and it doesn't seem like they're
writing parts for people like me that's
anything more than this right but yeah i
mean it's obviously so much better now
and i don't mean i think some people
might read my book and think i speak
hyperbolically about myself or or i'm
taking the piss out of myself too much
but
it was it was truly a different world
right
for a guy who looked like me at that
time
right and this kind of led you into when
you did drake and josh it was sort of
the same thing well yeah drake was so
amanda was on all that which was like
snl for kids right she got amanda show
drake and i were on amanda show and we
got our own show a year later they liked
you guys that much that you just
blossomed on the show yeah you got your
own show
yeah they called the guy who created all
that and amanda show this guy dan
schneider and they were like do you have
another like
buddy comedy idea because he had made
keenan and cal
and he said nope
they were like great well if you have an
idea let us know
and
drake and i are doing a scene towards
the last episode of the season
and this guy steve milaro who's now you
know huge writer and and producer for
chuck laurie he goes over to dan and
goes um don't they want you to write a
buddy comedy and he said yeah he said
it's those two idiots like those really
he's like that's your b those are your
buddies
and six months later we were on the set
of drake and josh were you were you
shocked that you're getting your own
show
seemed like that's how it worked
like oh this is how hollywood works like
you do good on one show and then you get
your own show at least for kids tv and
your mom is in la with you because you
moved with her from new york to l.a yeah
she's there to support you we've got a
two-bedroom apartment at the avalon i'm
talking amenities like a racquetball
court
um what a treat carpet
carpet nice carpet a fridge with the ice
dispenser
like we could not we were literally
happy we could not believe
how good our life was
you